in the last video we tried to relate
what 13.7 billion years really means by
compressing it to 10 years which is
still a pretty long time at least from
our perspective and we saw that these
huge periods of time everything that's
happened since the declaration of the
united states declaration of
independence
all gets compressed into just five
seconds and that's you know that's
that's not much when you think about 10
years i mean 10 years you could wait
around a lot that's that's a huge amount
of time so hopefully that put things put
things in perspective a little bit what
i want to do in this video is kind of do
the same thing but relate the 13.7
billion years if that were a distance or
the length of a timeline how big each of
these periods would be so just to start
off the timeline i'm recording this in
high definition right now there's there
should be 1280 pixels wide depending on
where you're watching it so maybe you're
watching on a high def tv if the
timeline was the width
of my screen right over here
if the timeline was the width of my
screen here so if that was 13.7 billion
years from there
let's say this is the beginning of the
universe and this is our present time if
that was
13.7b years the amount of time that
humans have been on this planet
monitored humans the people who look and
think like us the amount of time that we
have been on this planet will not even
be a pixel this little dot i drew is
multiple pixels the the the amount of
time we've been here would not even be a
pixel in fact a pixel and that dot i
drew here is about four pixels but a
pixel
just one little pixel on my screen would
represent 11 million years
11 let me scroll over it would represent
11 million
million
years so this was the timeline the
dinosaurs the dinosaurs would have been
extinct about six pixels from the end so
it would be right about
so six pixels from the end is when the
dinosaurs would have gotten extinct and
the amount of time that modern humans
are on the planet wouldn't even register
here it'd be 1 20th of that pixel over
there in fact we could if we just
expanded that very last pixel
if we were to expand that very last
pixel i'll do it in yellow that very
last tiny pixel that you can't see if we
were expand that to the entire length of
this screen again
if we were to so if we were to just
expand just that very last pixel so i'm
saying everything on this yellow line
could be contained in that very last
dot right over there then every pixel in
this
then every pixel in this would still be
would still be 8 000
8 000 years so the entire period of time
that humanity has been on this planet on
this scale on this scale so we've broken
out this little tiny pixel here all the
way out here 200 000 years that's on the
order of about 25 of these pixels so 25
of these pixels would be
something like
something like that not probably not
even that not even that so 25 pixels on
the screen at least at my resolution is
about that distance so this is the
fraction of just that pixel that is the
amount of time humans have been on the
planet if you want the time since jesus
it would be 1 4 of a pixel on this
yellow scale
on this yellow scale it would be 1 4 of
a pixel and the amount of time since the
declaration of independence would be
even a more even a more miniscule amount
of time so that's one way to think about
it but these timelines to some degree
also don't give justice so another way
to think about what if we had a timeline
that that stretched from here where i am
in the san francisco bay if it stretched
1300 kilometers to to seattle so if this
thing stretched 1300 kilometers all the
way to seattle then how so this thing
the big bang would be sitting in seattle
this would be sitting in seattle the the
universe well the universe or the the
formation of the earth and the solar
system this would be about about 200
kilometers away a little over 200
kilometers and in the direction of
seattle i don't know that would get us
in probably some part of northern
california with redwoods and and whatnot
but just to give an idea of 200
kilometers that would get me from where
i am at near the coast of california to
about the nevada border so still a
pretty good distance relative to the
entire timeline
the the dinosaurs the the the the last
land dinosaurs when the dinosaurs when
the earth got hit by an asteroid this so
remember the our whole timeline now
stretches all the way to seattle this
event now would have only occurred this
event would have only occurred about
three thousand meters away
about three
thousand or maybe i should just say
three kilometers away or roughly about
two miles so that still seems like a
pretty good distance but remember our
timeline stretches all the way to
seattle from the san francisco area so
it's a pretty big timeline so this is
already a pretty small distance but it
gets even smaller australopithecus
this right over here this
when they were roaming the earth three
million years ago this gets reduced to a
little bit more than a football field
about 150
meters not kilometers let me write that
in a color that you can where there's
some contrast 150
meters is where so 150 meters in the
direction of seattle if that's the
timeline that we're talking about and
then the first humans even shorter it's
only going to be 10 meters 10 meters of
this timeline that stretches all the way
all the way to seattle the birth of
jesus
birth of jesus 2000 years ago 2000 years
ago would be 10 centimeters 10
centimeters on a timeline that stretches
from san francisco to seattle and then
finally the declaration of independence
the american declaration of independence
would be one centimeter
one centimeter on a timeline that
stretches to seattle
anyway i don't know if that made it uh
if that put things in more or less
perspective but but it was worth giving
it giving it a shot